[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio y las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo
ante la situación de kobe 19 ahora
trabajamos desde casa un reportaje de la
televisión francesa dedicado a denunciar
los cosas en las clandestinas en parís
provocó un escándalo en el país galo y
no solo por llevar a cabo este tipo de
eventos en el marco de un tercer
confinamiento destinado a frenar el
aumento en el número de contagios de
kobe 19 sino también por acusaciones de
que varios ministros habrían
presuntamente participado de estas
reuniones el tema ha despertado la
indignación de los franceses en redes
sociales quienes piden que se revelen
los nombres de los implicados el
ministro del interior anunció una
investigación al respecto y negó la
presencia de otros colegas en estas
celebraciones aquí se lo explicamos
empezamos
en francia los bares y restaurantes
permanecen cerrados desde finales de
octubre de 2020 con el objetivo de
frenar la propagación del cob y 19 pero
un reportaje del canal de televisión m6
denunció una serie de supuestas
exclusivas y lujosas cenas que se están
celebrando en parís de manera
clandestina este medio de comunicación
dijo que tres de sus periodistas
entraron con cámara oculta estas fiestas
en la capital francesa que además de ser
ilegales no exigen el uso de mascarillas
ni otras medidas de seguridad como el
distanciamiento social la noticia
provocó gran revuelo en un país que
sufre duras restricciones francia
actualmente atraviesa un tercer
confinamiento debido al repunte en los
contagios de coronavirus y un aumento en
el número de hospitalizaciones pero lo
que más ha indignado a los franceses es
el testimonio de una fuente que dijo que
varios ministros han estado presentes en
dichas reuniones
parte del reportaje fue compartido en la
cuenta de twitter del canal en sí se
hizo viral en cuestión de minutos y ya
ha sido visto por casi 4 millones de
personas a través del numeral o un fondo
de lo que traduce queremos nombres
usuarios en redes sociales reclaman la
lista de los funcionarios del gobierno
que presuntamente han hecho parte de las
fiestas clandestinas al tiempo que
especulan sobre los posibles asistentes
los medios de comunicación en los
internautas rápidamente pudieron
identificar que la fuente que advertía
sobre la participación de ministros era
jack jones charlize son un empresario
que dirige un restaurante en el centro
de parís y aquí en los medios reconocen
como un coleccionista de piezas de
napoleón y una figura cercana a
personajes de extrema derecha de la
política francesa hablando con la cadena
bfm-tv el hombre aceptó que si fue él
pero pareció retractarse de sus
comentarios sobre los ministros y dijo
que se trató de una broma
si la gente no tiene un poco de humor es
porque no entendieron nada fue un gran
día de los inocentes que funcionó pero
no pensé que resultaría de esa manera
pero a pesar de sus declaraciones el
furor en redes sociales no se detuvo y
quienes menos se lo tomaron con humor
fueron las autoridades y altos
funcionarios del gobierno francés tras
la publicación del reportaje la fiscalía
de parís anunció la apertura de una
investigación criminal por poner en
peligro la vida de terceros y para
determinar quiénes serán los posibles
organizadores y asistentes el portavoz
del gobierno gabriel a tal dijo que no
creía que hubiera presencia de ministros
en esas cenas el ministro de economía
bruno le maire dijo que todos respetan
las reglas y el ministro del interior
llega al that man and pidió a la policía
verificar los hechos y enjuiciar a los
responsables en una entrevista a la
emisora ojo con el funcionario aseguró
que en ningún miembro del gobierno había
participado de las polémicas cenas y
criticó a johnson por hacer publicidad
falsa que según dijo puede salirle muy
caro
por un lado no están los burgueses a los
que se les permitiría seguir festejando
y por el otro las personas que vendrían
a ser controladas la regla se aplica a
todos este rumor socava los cimientos de
la democracia y socava profundamente la
confianza que tenemos en nuestras
instituciones tras el revuelo la
sociedad de periodistas de noticias de
emesis defendió su reportaje a través de
un comunicado refutó las acusaciones de
calumnia en contra de su redacción
sobre este punto otras fuentes nos han
confirmado inof la presencia de al menos
un miembro del gobierno de una de estas
cenas continuamos nuestras
investigaciones sobre este tema con
ministros de ministros en dichas cenas
la sociedad francesa no deja pasar este
tipo de acontecimientos según dicen los
medios de comunicación la cadena el xii
dice las elegantes en las parisinas
organizadas en medio de una crisis
sanitaria suscitan polémica en el último
episodio hasta la fecha el presunto
organizador asegura que todo fue una
gran broma pero no convence en su
editorial titulado las cenas
clandestinas y la olla a presión el
diario la opinión dice que no importa lo
que establezca la justicia real
jueces de internet ya han emitido su
veredicto la edición francesa del portal
huffington post titula restaurantes
clandestinos la indignación que revela
una profunda crisis y agrega que la
polémica por las cenas es una nueva
señal de creciente desconfianza hacia
los políticos con la crisis del cobi 19
y para el cierre uno de los sitios más
populares de la web dice adiós tras 16
años operando se trata de yahoo
respuestas que ahora se parte del grupo
verizon media a partir del 20 de abril
la plataforma ya no aceptará más
preguntas y cerrará definitivamente el 4
de mayo el sitio que había servido para
preguntar y responder desde las dudas
más simples hasta las más extrañas
reconoció que se ha vuelto menos popular
a lo largo de los años a medida que las
necesidades de sus miembros han cambiado
y que por ello decidió desviar sus
recursos para enfocarse en productos que
sirvan mejor a su comunidad
hasta aquí revista digital recuerde que
se quiere repetir esta u otra emisión de
nuestro programa lo puede hacer a través
de nuestra página web www puntos francia
24 punto com
[Música]